il est midi les clients affluent mais
avant d'entrer l'incontournable contrôle
de base sanitaires pas vraiment du goût
de ces tristes et
l'annoncent on va dire gouvernementale
nous on avait mis un panneau extérieur
voit là pour dire notre mécontentement
parce que c'était ponot trop non plus
d'assumer les errances stratégique du
gouvernement voilà ce qu'explique et
dans le sens où ne pas le rendre
obligatoire mais rendre le pass
sanitaire obligatoire basses étaient
déchargés sur nos professions le rôle
d'agent en fait de contrôler le panneau
qu'hélène a déposé à l'extérieur déplaît
aux pros vaccination un tombereau
d'insultés et de reproches abondent sur
internet
pour autant cela ne décourage pas et
l'aisne après sept mois de fermeture
elle et ses collègues n'ont qu'une envie
travail et nous appliquons les règles
sanitaires et d'ailleurs à la preuve
c'est que dix jours avant j'avais je me
suis fait cracher dessus par un client
que j'ai viré parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'ils se déplacer dans
le restaurant sans porter son masque et
que j'ai fini par le sortir parce qu'il
ne voulait pas porter son masque presque
parce que y'en a marre de toutes ces
conneries comme ils disaient etc etc peu
importe les règles sont les règles et
nous on les respecte bon gré mal gré
le manque de personnel se fait de plus
en plus ressentir pourtant les
restaurateurs avaient lancé l' alerte
alors pour faire respecter ces nouvelles
règles et contrôles et en plus des
masques l'epasa ni terre elle a l'idée
de faire appel à des retraités pour lui
venir en aide on a reçu des menaces les
la secrétaire et la directrice de l'eemi
85 ont reçu des coups de fil
d'un culte en se faisant traiter de
facho de collabo de la part pour le coup
surtout d'anti vax en fait et on a reçu
aussi des menaces d'un collectif qui
disait que si on faisait appel à ces
retraités et bien
il ferait appel à leurs avocats contre
nous
dans l'impasse hélène n'a plus le choix
et doit faire avec ces cinq serveurs
aujourd'hui c'est le cuisinier qui
contrôle les patients ni terre un
impératif afin que cette restauratrice
limite au maximum ses pertes financières
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la
nouvelle loi certains établissements
vendéens ont vu leur chiffre d'affaires
chuter de moitié